thank you
all right everybody
[Music]
all right our next guest um has been in
front of a camera since she was 10
months old she has me beat by a month
I'm so excited to talk about that please
welcome Journey Smollett
[Applause]
hi
oh my God I just want everyone to see
this outfit
it's like Olivia Newton-John you know
like Diana Ross
I mean
and the red corresponding belt jacket
and shoes well I mean listen my my
stylist is going to love the fact that
you've noticed all these details we have
a lot of fun
um okay is it true that you started in a
photography campaign
in a diaper at 10 months old this is
true I can't believe it I believe you
are you
[Applause]
I was 11 months old ah man then we
become adults and we get to do certain
projects and I gotta tell you everyone
your new movie
with Allison Janney Lou is so amazing
like
let me
toss really quickly uh to a clip because
I want you guys to just see the vibe get
the tone
I gotta get to the chair I'll drive
all right
yeah
it's pretty intense
it's this crazy Thriller action
adventure and I get to spend the entire
film in the mud and the rain with Alice
and Janie kicking but Academy
award-winning yeah brilliant actress and
she's 61 years old when we shot this and
when I tell you she and I did her did
all of our own stunts but she went like
watching her on set my jaw was just open
the entire time because she was kicking
butt she kills it and you've got
Allison's character who devoted her
whole life to service of her country my
character devoted her whole life to her
daughter and my daughter's kidnapped and
we are forced to work together and can't
stand each other and judge each other
for very for taking these very different
paths and there are big secrets a lot of
secret that get revealed and it has
twists and turns and yet it's you two
women and that's just so great to see
thank you um is it true you were eight
years old when you were cast in your
first film this is true Jack it was with
Robin Williams a little great Robin
Williams it was directed
below oh my God it was
so your first film is with
um you know Francis Ford Coppola and
Robin Williams yeah like one of the
greatest actors to ever live and one of
the greatest filmmakers to ever live you
know I've been fortunate throughout my
career to work with the great and to
learn from them working with with these
great filmmakers and actors that's how I
learned you know working with Samuel
Jackson that was my second film he was
by you you know I I learned so much from
Sam being on on film with him I'm with
you I've been learning on the job my
whole life Denzel Washington said to me
he said you do by doing I'm not name
dropping I'm really not they dropping
names no no but he said you do by doing
and I really believe that it's like
you've got to jump into the ocean and
you gotta just swim you know and and I
like you I feel so fortunate to be able
to do what I love to be paid to do what
I love you know to bring these stories
to life these different complex women
you know
thank you we're telling us the story of
Robin and Denzel and Samuel Jackson and
you know of course the incredible
Allison Janney you and her are taking a
real ride that usually men take and this
is all women and it is so good just in
time
[Applause]
stick around we have a heart attack a
hack attack that's later it sounds like
a heart attack it's not that oh we'll be
back
[Music]
foreign